[Musique]
les essentielles du sénat
lutte contre les algues vertes des
avancées mais pas à la hauteur des
enjeux
en 2021 la prolifération d'algues vertes
en bretagne a connu un niveau historique
les mesures prises par les pouvoirs
publics pour lutter contre cette
pollution sont elles en deçà des enjeux
le sénateur bernard delcros rapporteur
spécial de la mission budgétaire
cohésion des territoires avait présenté
en mai 2021 au nom de la commission des
finances les conclusions de son travail
de contrôle sur l'efficacité des moyens
de lutte contre les marées vertes sur la
côte bretonne
dix mois plus tard le sénateur dresse un
bilan contrasté du suivi des
recommandations de son rapport
les modifications de la réglementation
la mise à disposition de nouveaux outils
à destination des exploitants agricoles
et la hausse significative des crédits
consacrés à la lutte contre les marées
vertes sont des évolutions majeures
souhaité par l'auteur du rapport
bernard delcros approuve la hausse de 6
millions d'euros qui devrait être
accordée après 2022 à la lutte contre
les algues vertes au travers du
programme des interventions territoriale
de l'état
il salue la révision du programme
d'action régional de lutte contre la
pollution par les nitrates et les
améliorations concernant la gouvernance
du plan de lutte contre les algues
vertes
le sénateur se félicite par exemple de
la création de programmes d'actions
spécifiques à chaque baie algues vertes
sous la forme de zones soumises à
contraintes environnementales
en outre il accueille favorablement la
mise en place de financements européens
dédiés aux baies à algues vertes dans le
cadre de la pac
malgré cela bernard delcros estime que
ces évolutions ne permettent pas
d'obtenir à court terme des résultats
probants
les actions préventives dans les
vasières du morbihan par exemple reste
lacunaire
par ailleurs les nouvelles mesures
réglementaires ne seront pas
contraignante avant 2025 au plus tôt et
vont être limité pour l'instant aux
agriculteurs volontaires
bernard delcros regrette enfin que les
crédits consacrés à la lutte contre la
pollution par les nitrates soit sans
commune mesure avec les aides de droit
commun de la pac
le rapporteur spécial souhaite une
réorientation des crédits de la pac vers
davantage d'être conditionnée au respect
des pratiques agricoles prenant en
compte le contexte environnemental
spécifiques de ces territoires
il se prononce parallèlement en faveur
d'une augmentation des effectifs de
contrôle des exploitations agricoles
pour en savoir plus consultez la
synthèse du suivi des recommandations du
rapport
[Musique]